ils font partie des six monuments du
centre Val de Loire retenu pour le loto
du patrimoine oui avant de vous dévoiler
ces deux édifices situés en
Indre-et-Loire et Loir-et-Cher d'abord
notre question web l'auto du patrimoine
allez-vous acheter un ticket c'est oui
pour 10 % d'entre vous c'est déjà pas
mal depuis 2018 plus de 125 millions
d'euros ont ainsi pu être collectés pour
sauver le patrimoine en péril chez nous
de monuments donc profiteront des fonds
de la mission Berne le château du temple
de à tonneuil dans le Sud Touraine qui
appartenu à la chanteuse Nana Mouskouri
je sais que ça vous tient un coeur
Aurélien ainsi que l'ancienne auberge
des trois canards à la Ferté Beauharnais
en Loir-et-Cher focus justement ce soir
sur le monument solonio déjà mentionné
il y a plus de 500 ans sous le règne de
Louis X l'Auberge des trois canards fait
partie de ses auberges très fréquentées
à l'époque aujourd'hui en péril d'une
association tente de la sauver voyage
reportage d'Hélène chapelet
pour pénétrer dans l'an
cienne obéir un chemin parmi la
végétation le bâtiment qui date 2464
n'est plus habitées depuis déjà
plusieurs années il est aujourd'hui la
propriété de la mairie de la
Ferté-Beauharnais qui a pris un arrêté
de mise en péril au vu de son état de
délabrement exceptionnellement le maire
nous autorise à filmer le
rez-de-chaussée la maison à pente bois
et en torchies prend l'eau une première
estimation fait état de 800000 euros de
travaux
malheureusement les propriétaires
pendant de très nombreuses années n'ont
pas fait un centime de travaux et voilà
pourquoi on se retrouve dans une
situation telle
la Fondation Berne bien sûr c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour notre commune
bon sachant que le montant est malgré
tout plafonné et qui représente que
en gros si nous avons le maximum un
tiers des travaux enfin du de
l'estimative des travaux donc il faudra
qu'on aille à la pêche à d'autres
subventions ça va être le parcours du
combattant et ça risque de durer un
petit peu de temps malgré tout
l'ancienne auberge situé au centre du
village
trop Paris et Toulouse c'est entre ces
murs kalexandre de boharnais militaire
et maire du village aurait tenu une
vingtaine de conseils municipaux en
1793 un lieu de mémoire que le loto du
patrimoine devrait sauver de la
démolition